bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct ce matin sur rtl france
alors vous revendiquez évidemment tous
les deux l'héritage du général de gaulle
pourquoi cette figure de la france est
particulièrement présente cette année en
tout cas dans la campagne jean marc
flipo
alors on revendique pas l'héritage du
général de gaulle nous sommes un parti
le gaullisme dire que nous inspirons
bien évidemment de ce que fut le le
gaullisme et de ceux des actions du
général de gaulle notamment pendant la
guerre mais on n'a pas de brevet le
colis sera distribué on sent garderai
bien
nicolas dupont aignan et est imprégnée
par le général de gaulle depuis qu'il
est tout petit il a commencé sa carrière
politique en collant des affiches pour
chaban en 74 et en 99 il a créé le club
debout la république qui avait pour
vocation justement de rassembler et
sympathisants et les aigus gaulliste au
sein d'une ump dont on sait déjà qu'elle
a évolué vers à un schéma plutôt social
démocrate dont classé dans cette c'est
dans cette tradition que nous nous
inscrivons
le pourquoi nicolas dupont aignan est
allé à colombey tous les ans sans
exception y compris l'année dernière
donc c'est un une forme de rituel
pourquoi parce que en fait c'est cette
certaine idée de la france dont parlait
le général de gaulle qui nous apprennent
et toute notre action politique
ce en fête se tient à l'aune de cette de
cette certaine idée de la france et moi
je aujourd'hui le 9 9 ans et c'est
l'occasion plongé dans un corpus de
citation du général qui est quasiment
inépuisable il ya une phrase qu'il ya
une phrase du général de gaulle qui
résume très bien tout ça qui part de la
démocratie le généraliser que la
démocratie c'est le gouvernement du
peuple qui s'exerce qui exerce sa
souveraineté sans entrave voilà cette
notion de souveraineté nationale qui qui
est fondamental une souveraineté que
nous avons perdu un certain nombre de
personne d'ailleurs qui vont défiler
aujourd'hui devant la tombe du général
le monde ont contribué à nous faire
lâcher des pans entiers de souveraineté
et je pense que c'est une occasion
je prie de vulgaires de rappeler que
voilà sans souveraineté il y a quand
même beaucoup moins de démocratie
grandeur de la france déclin même les
thèmes qui avaient été soulevés par le
général de gaulle sont sont très
présents dans cette campagne
présidentielle la revendication du du
gaullisme est un passage obligé pour les
candidats justement l approche de cette
élection jean philippe dugoin clément
je sais pas si c'est un passage obligé
ou pas la réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui
quasiment toute la classe politique
française se reconnaît dans le message
les valeurs l'incarnation qui a été
portée inspiré par le général de gaulle
que ce soit l'homme du 18 juin que ce
soit l'homme de la libération que ce
soit le chef d'état
la vie du général de gaulle a été
particulièrement d'arges et aujourd'hui
il incarne pour toute une partie de la
france pour toute une partie des
politiques français mais au delà des
politiques avec des élus des citoyens
parce qu'au fond délai légal et les élus
ne sont que les représentants aient à
l'image des citoyens une vision d'une
france qui avance d'une france qui a
confiance en demain d'une france qui a
existe qui a un poids politique et qui
est capable de tendre vers une forme
d'universalisme cdma nordiste réllement
forte en france qui n'existe plus
aujourd'hui
une france qui doutent aujourd'hui et je
crois qu'aujourd'hui alors que on est
dans un pays qui se cherche qui a
énormément d'inquiétude qui est
confronté à des difficultés des images
comme celles du général de gaulle sont
des images qui rassemble au delà même de
ce qu'ils ont pu parfois rassembler leur
époque pas si on se place à la fin de
l'époque du gaullisme on a été sur des
périodes très dur très contesté et
pourtant aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose
qui rassemble c'est devenu un symbole
d'unité nationale moi je me réjouis même
si effectivement des fois on peut avoir
un certain nombre de surprises
idéologique par rapport à des courants
des tendances politiques qui viennent se
réclamer du gaullisme qui de fait
pendant des années ont combattu le
général de gaulle lorsqu'il était au
pouvoir ou en situation d'exercer le
pouvoir ouais ça c'est le cas du du
front national rassemblement national de
marine le pen marine le pen qui sera
présente aujourd'hui mais pas elle ne
croisera pas nicolas dupont aignan où
florian philippot puisque la candidate
du rassemblement national préfère se
rendre à bayeux où le général a tenu un
discours sur les institutions en 46
cette revendication du du gaullisme fait
partie d'ailleurs de la transformation
du lieu du rassemblement national vous
voyez ce qu'en dit jordan bardella il
parle de ce fameux abou présidentielle
ou femme présidentielle tant attendue en
france tant regretté en tous cas dont le
fils de l'été le général de gaulle
explique que les deux qualités
essentielles d'un chef et d'un dirigeant
politique sont l'autorité et l'instinct
et je pense que ce sont les traits de
personnalité de marine le pen l'instinct
parce qu'elle a imposée dans le débat
public l'intégralité des thèmes qui font
aujourd'hui le débat public
l'immigration la critique de la
mondialisation sauvage les dérives de
l'union européenne la défense des
classes populaires et puis l'autorité
parce que je crois qu'elle a l'autorité
nécessaire pour rétablir l'ordre dans le
pays le faire dans l'union nationale et
rassembler les français et d'ailleurs le
général de gaulle tenait à ce
dépassement des clivages partisans il
n'était ni de droite ni de gauche il
était de france et je crois que ça
correspond bien aujourd'hui à ce que
nous sommes et jean-marc chipeau tout le
monde peut se revendiquer de de
l'héritage de du gaullisme
attendait encore une fois personne ne
peut descendre des voies vers gaullisme
simplement lorsque l'on a un parc au
québec et celui du front national moi je
pense que le jeu part commenté le
dantesque dujardin jordan dare de l'âme
et le front national pouvait très bien
choisir des figures tutélaires qui lui
ressemble plus s'en aller piocher
nécessairement dans le
le gaullisme c'est avec au long bec
bayeux c'est palourdes un fait pas acte
de rédemption pense que lorsque l'on se
rend à sedan c'est dans ces lieux mais
je pense que je me réjouis de toute
manière que effectivement cette certaine
idée de la france dont je parlais
ressurgissent c'est une longue
discussion de cette idée de la france
une incarnation forte avec un homme un
homme fort à la tête du pays c'est et
c'est en ça que jordan garder la cadence
guardian à l'heure actuelle quand la
soupe vous prenez c'est ce que tout le
monde
vous n'avez pas à l'heure actuelle a
donc providentiel en ski c'était l'objet
de votre question le paysage politique
français ne présentent pas d'homme
providentiel comme il y en a pas en
allemagne que n'y en a pas radical il
n'y en a pas aux états unis c'est
peut-être l'époque qui veut ça c'est
peut être effectivement une certaine
érosion de la démocratie occidentale qui
veut ça et pourtant les français le
réclament a priori et dans les périodes
où effectivement les pays les nations
perdent un peu de leur certitude c'est
un star et flex naturel que de de
vouloir chercher l'homme providentiel
nous nous préférons dire que nous avons
tous en nous mêmes et est précisément si
si le gaullisme ne doit nous enseigner
quelque chose c'est ça c'est de se dire
qu'elle accélère de même avec des
valeurs qui nous ont constitué la france
est une vieille démocratie aujourd'hui
nous avons tout ce qu'il faut en
nous-mêmes pour pouvoir nous
reconstruire et nous projeter dans
l'avenir parce que le gaullisme c'est
aussi ça c'est pouvoir se projeter dans
l'avenir indépendamment des difficultés
sur fille a des difficultés résister à
la facilité et dieu sait que la
tentation est grande à l'heure actuelle
pour se reconstruire et effectivement il
ya nécessité de rassembler aujourd'hui
la nation alors qu'il ya des tentations
séparatistes un peu dans tous les sens
donc il ya nécessité de rassembler la
nation dans un projet à un horizon de 30
50 ans et de pouvoir représenter la
france qui est un oeuf dur
général disait que ont fait pas
d'omelette avec des oeufs durs les
nations sont des zones où la france est
un oeuf dur donc il faut la prendre
comme tel et je suis désolé on a tout ce
qu'il faut dans nos mains pour que pour
retrouver
grandeur parce qu'il sera pas la
grandeur passée de la france mais qui
sera la croix de la france disait la
grandeur de la france et réconcilier un
pays réconcilié les français c'est aussi
participer au rayonnement de la france à
l'extérieur quel constat vous faites
jean philippe dugoin clément sur ce
rayonnement de la france à l'extérieur
aujourd'hui yat il beaucoup de choses à
faire pour le pour l'arc pour le
rétablir ce rayonnement
la france reste un grand pays ça reste
une grande joie dans le monde une voix
qui lui fait de la mondialisation du
fait d'un certain nombre de pays
émergents qui ont pris des places
majeures a eu tendance à s'affaiblir et
aussi une loi qui a pu s'affaiblir parce
que lorsqu au sein même d'un pays vous
n'avez plus forcément la confiance ou la
conscience de ce que vous êtes allé
porter un message ou des valeurs qui
sont des valeurs universalistes les
valeurs du gaullisme
ces valeurs que aujourd'hui nous sommes
très nombreux à avoir en commun ces
débats le universal dissiper au
rayonnement de la france pendant son
mandat
il a comme tout chef d'état
participé en bien ou en mal avec des
réussites et des échecs au rayonnement
de la france on ne peut pas dire très
honnêtement que emmanuel macron n'a pas
existé sur la scène internationale par
contre ce qui est vrai c'est
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons un état un
pays qui se cherche un pays qui n'est
pas claire face à lui-même par rapport à
son histoire à son passé à ses valeurs
et que quand on est nous mêmes au sein
de notre pays dans une remise en cause
on voit que ces courants de pensée de ce
que nous sommes de ceux qui fait les
liens qui font que nous vivons ensemble
et bien c'est extrêmement dur d'aller
porter les messages et porter nos
valeurs à l'étranger et je pense qu'on a
aussi ce travail à faire sur nous mêmes
et au fond ce ce passage cette date
anniversaire du décès du général de
gaulle mais comme le 18 juin comme un
certain nombre d'autres dates c'est
aussi je crois le moment de rappeler que
la france est un pays uni mx1 et qui a
une histoire unique qui a une belle
histoire
il ya sur la base de cette belle
histoire un avenir et que cet avenir il
n'appartient qu'à nous de le porter mais
on ne peut pas le faire en étant dans
une logique de honte de ce que nous
sommes permanente et c'est à mon sens
quelque chose que nous payons
aujourd'hui et puis au delà de ça le
gaullisme c'est effectivement
une certaine manière une logique de deux
voix qui est capable d'être
indépendantes lorsqu'elles pensent
qu'elle est juste lorsqu'elle pense
qu'elle a un message à porter et je
crois que ç'a toujours été en tout cas
depuis l'après guerre depuis le 45 46 la
voix de la france dans le monde et c'est
une voie qui est original qui doit
continuer à être portées ça nécessite
beaucoup de choses ça nécessite d'être
une voix prépondérante au sein de
l'union européenne au sein de l'onu dans
l'ensemble des instances internationales
et si si
c'est d'une certaine manière l'image et
la grandeur de la france et on va parler
d'immigration ne reste pas beaucoup de
temps l'immigration est un thème
important de cette campagne
présidentielle voyez ce qu'en disait le
général de gaulle vous qui aimez des
récitations jean marc flipo
si une communauté n'ait pas accepté
c'est qu'elle ne donne pas de bons
produits sinon elle est admis sans
problème si elle se plaint de racisme à
son égard c'est parce qu'elle est
porteuse de désordre quand elle ne
fournit que du bien tout le monde lui
ouvre les bras mais il ne faut pas
qu'elles viennent chez nous imposer ses
moeurs et qui peut dire ça on encore
aujourd'hui jean marc flipo à part eric
zemmour peut-être
écouté il ya encore une fois les
citations c'est une chose il ya les
réalités mais j'ai été travailleur
immigré dans un dans un pays d'asie et
et je le touche du doigt très
précisément ce à quoi le général de
gaulle faisait allusion bien évidemment
qu'elle est quel est le projet
aujourd'hui je ne pense pas que la
france puisse résoudre que l'europe
puisse résoudre
la question d'immigration sans passer
par l'assimilation en tout cas la france
le modèle français est un modèle à six
ainsi mis la sioniste et à chaque fois
que l'on essaie dans notre pays
d'importer
le communautarisme anglo saxons on se
retrouve confronté à une montée des
tensions et montée des violences va je
pas si vous voyez l'heure actuelle de ce
qui se passe dans nos banlieues avant
vous avez des communautés qui se vante
la les unes contre les autres pas
nécessairement d'ailleurs envers la
communauté dite française de souche
acceptable même entre elles il faut
absolument qu'on résolve ce problème il
faut qu'on arrête cette politique
d'immigration massive qui ne permet pas
d'assimiler les nouveaux arrivants une
fois qu effectivement ce qui arrive ici
avec un projet professionnel à projets
qui puissent exercer de la meilleure des
manières et puis que ceux qui viennent
ici uniquement pour profiter d'un
système sans chercher le moins du monde
à y contribuer
jean philippe dugoin clément vous êtes
d'accord avec cette citation du général
de gaulle
presse et des citations 50 ans entend
150 ans après c'est extrêmement
compliqué qu'est ce que dirait le
général de gaulle aujourd'hui qu'est ce
qu'il aurait dit cinquante ans
auparavant
c'est pas que c'est pas inscrits
forcément dans un contexte historique
oui mais c'est c'est toujours la
transposition de ce que l'on est du
cadre de du cadre qui est celui au
moment où on prononce une phrase ce qui
est vrai dans la phrase qui est là c'est
le modèle d'intégration français modèle
d'intégration français c'est
effectivement un modèle qui est basé sur
le refus du communautarisme sur une
logique de communauté nationale et
d'intégration et au fond c'est ça qui
est important c'est un modèle profonde
et faire profondément différents des
modèles anglo-saxons les modèles
anglo-saxons américains notamment sont
basés sur un communautarisme admis ni
souhaité accepter entretenu d'une
certaine manière c'est absolument
antinomiques du modèle français qui est
un modèle totalement
intégrationniste autour des valeurs de
la république de cette certaine idée de
la france et le sujet majeur aujourd'hui
qui est double c'est que d'une part
nous ne choisissons plus l'immigration
accueilli dans notre pays c'est un
véritable
sujet nous portons avec nous défendons
avec valérie pécresse et puis d'autre
part c'est que intégrait des populations
lorsque l'on laisse petit à petit le
corpus idéologique français être
grignoté par des communautarismes qui ne
sont pas la tradition française c'est
quelque chose qui peut être remise en
péril le message de cette phrase ça doit
être le refus des communautaristes quels
qu'ils soient que ce sont des
communautarismes religieux des
communautarismes est unique la france ça
n'est pas le communautarisme alors il
reste peu de temps la vision de l'europe
du général de gaulle c'était une vision
plutôt continental une ambition aussi
pour pour cette europe et coûté
oui c'est l'europe depuis l'atlantique
jusqu'à l'oural c'est l'europe c'est
toute l'europe qui décidera du destin du
monde jean-marc chypre on la connaît
cette phrase est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ce constat l'europe doit
être continental on sait que le
gaullisme aussi c'est le refus de la
vassalisation de tous les organismes
internationaux comme l'onu comme l'otan
ou même la communauté européenne à
l'époque
oui bien évidemment
savez la russie la russie et européennes
lorsque l'on a lorsqu'on est aligné
aveuglément sur la politique américaine
qui consiste à rejeter la russie vers la
chine c'est très dangereux aujourd'hui
depuis que depuis qu'on est passé à un
stade du conte a réintégré le
commandement intégré de l'otan depuis le
traité de lisbonne en étant serein de
justement le rap est en train de
disparaître de la scène internationale
l'europe politique aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
que c'est un nain alors qu' il ya encore
25 ans de cela l'europe avait pour
ambition de peser politiquement dans
l'avenir du monde aujourd'hui on
s'aperçoit que 102 l'invité de la
planète s'est déplacé vers la zone indo
pacifique alors qu'effectivement
l'europe avec toute son histoire une
richesse incroyable exploit économique
l'europe devrait pouvoir peser notamment
pour apaiser les tensions qui se
développent un peu partout à à la
surface du globe on a raté le coche je
pense que on doit passer par une refonte
complète de leroy pendant renégocier
complètement des tripiers
européen rendre aux nations
l'important ce qui est la leur parce
qu'il n'y a que de cette manière qu'elle
puisse qu'elle puisse vraiment
s'exprimer est pesé et c'est en
coopérant mais ça aussi je pense que
c'était je veux pas paraître et cela
parce que c'était la vision e du général
d'eurostar les coopérations
industrielles que l'on peut
effectivement vérifier cette europe qui
se disloque un peu partout ces rebus
c'est encore cette coopération
effectivement il reste 30 secondes jean
philippe dugoin clément je vous laisse
le mot de la fin vraiment très court sur
cette vision de l'europe du général de
gaulle est la vôtre
l'europe malheureusement c'est un géant
économique et 1,1 politique l'europe
c'est le seul moyen pour la france
aujourd'hui en termes de poids
économique et démographique
d'influer sur le monde pour autant ça ne
peut exister que si la france est un
acteur majeur si la france et la voix de
l'europe et s'il approche utilise le
rock pour porter les valeurs et le
message qui est le sien c'est justement
est-ce qu'on peut arriver de faire de la
robe de l'europe un acteur politique
mondiale majeure ce qu'elle n'est pas
aujourd'hui merci beaucoup à tous les
deux merci jean marc flipo je rappelle
que vous êtes porte-parole de vous la
france et jean philippe dugoin clément
porte-parole les républicains de valérie
pécresse merci beaucoup pour votre
participation ce matin au débat de la
matinale verser france